HASHTAG WARS.
>> WE WILL HAPPILY BE
CELEBRATING COMEDY CENTRAL'S
SHART WEEK WITH TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG, #SHARTCELEBS.
>> SO EXAMPLES MIGHT BE FECES
WITHERSPOON, OR DWAYNE THE LOG
JOHNSON, OR CHRIS SPLAT.
>> I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK STARTING NOW AND GO.
>> MOSHE.
>> BRAD (BLEEP) AND ANGELINA
DOOK-IE.
>> YES, GOOD, POINTS. NICE.
JESSE.
>> DYSENTERY BRADSHAW.
>> YEAH, OK, GOOD. POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> BRADLEY POOPER, CRAP
GALIFIANAKIS AND ED "DIARRHEA"
HELMS IN HANG OVER POOP.
>> WOW.
>> I AM GOING TO GIVE YOU 200
POINTS FOR THAT.
JESSE.
>> IS MY (BLEEP) WORKING, MAN?
>> Chris: NO, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR HAND ON THE BUZZER.
>> YOU HAVE TO HIT THE BUTTON.
>> I HIT THE (BLEEP) TWICE, MAN.
>> JESSE.
>> I HAVE NEVER FEET LIKE I WAS
GOING TO GET PUNCHED MORE.
>> JOHN MEXICAN TAP WATERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DONNEL.
>> FOR THE BLACK PEOPLE, DR.
REVEREND SHARTIN' LUTHER KING.
>> Chris: WOW, POINTS. MOSHE.
TAYLOR SWIFTLY GET ME HOME I AM
ABOUT TO (BLEEP) MY PANTS.
>> POINTS. JESSE.
>> EDWARD JAMES ALMOST
(BLEEP) MYSELF.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
DONNELL.
>> OH, JESSE AGAIN. SORRY.
>> MAN!
>> JESUS CHRIST.
>> ABRAHAM BLUMPKIN.
>> Chris: YES! BY THE WAY--
AS WE ALL KNOW, WAS SHOT BY JOHN
WILKES POOTH.
>> POINTS.
DONNEL.
>> SHART-KEEL O'NEILL.
>> Chris: YEAH, NICE, POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> SARAH PALIN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DONNEL.
>> SHART-SENIO! HALL!
>> POOP, POOP, POOP, POOP!!